a brand new 25-year-old model is raking
in nearly
$11,000 per month for her modeling
agency in Barcelona but it's especially
impressive because this hot little
Spaniard is not a human she's a computer
model model created by AI to look
perfect and unlike most developments in
AI which I suspect will degrade us all
before wiping out human life entirely
Terminator style in the case of aana
that's her name it's kind of clever
right if titillating job must exist I am
all for giving them to computers it's
not because I have anything against
human models I actually really care
about human models and because of that I
want them to lose their jobs to
computers because modeling generally is
terrible for women very often they end
up being exploited and degraded and
treated as an object and a commodity in
themselves and it's just not really good